in previous videos we have talked at
length about fiscal policy and in other
videos we've talked at length about
monetary policy but now we're going to
talk about them together because at any
given time in a country there is some
type of fiscal policy going on and in
parallel there might be some type of
monetary policy going on
but first let's just remind ourselves
what fiscal policy is
this would be government changing the
amount of taxes or government spending
so this is all about taxes
and or
government
government spending
and why would that matter well if you
change the amount of taxes you change
the amount of money that individuals and
or corporations might have which might
change aggregate demand similarly if the
government goes out there spends less
more or less that also would change
aggregate demand and this could be used
as a tool
in order to attempt to engineer what the
economy's output is
now monetary policy on the other hand
it's very important not get not to get
confused between these two this is all
about central
central banks and i know a lot of you
might be thinking hey isn't the central
bank part of the government and i would
tell you well it depends what country
you're in and depends how you view part
of the government in the united states
for example the federal reserve system
is
quasi-independent it is true that the
executive makes appointments including
the chairman of the federal reserve bank
but it should be acting independently
from the federal government and this is
all about central banks changing money
supply
so money supply
to impact or to target oftentimes
interest rates
and now why would this matter if we're
thinking about engineering so to speak
where we are relative to full employment
output well with low interest rates
borrowing is cheaper so people might be
willing to borrow and spend more or
corporations might be willing to borrow
and invest more on the other hand if you
had higher interest rates it would go
the other way either way you have an
impact on aggregate demand
so with that primer out of the way let's
look at two different scenarios for an
economy
so in this first scenario let's call
this scenario one pause the video and
think about where this economy is
operating relative to full employment
output
well you can see here that our
equilibrium level of output y sub one is
below our full employment output
so here we have a negative output gap
and so from the federal government's
point of view they might want to say hey
let's do some expansionary fiscal policy
in order to shift the aggregate demand
curve to the right
well what would be expansionary fiscal
policy
well you could lower taxes
that could shift aggregate demand to the
right people would have more money in
their pockets corporations might have
more money to spend with to invest with
the other option is that the government
could just directly spend more if it
spends more that also would have the
impact of shifting aggregate demand to
the right
but in parallel with the fiscal policy
what might the monetary policy look like
well an expansionary monetary policy
would be to
increase the money supply
with the goal
which would have the impact or usually
would have the impact of lowering
interest rates
which would make borrowing cheaper and
so corporations might invest more and
people might borrow and spend more
either way or especially if both is
happening you are going to shift
aggregate demand to the right so with
this expansionary fiscal and monetary
policy you might get to a situation like
this maybe aggregate demand gets shifted
enough
so we get to a
world like this so that's aggregate
demand curve 2. we're now our
equilibrium level of output we're at
full employment output and our price
level has gone
has gone up and generally speaking
expansionary policy whether we're
talking about expansionary fiscal policy
or expansionary monetary policy you're
going to see the price level go up
now let's look at scenario two here
what are we dealing with here
well as you can imagine it's the
opposite situation we have a positive
output gap our equilibrium level of
output is above our full employment
output and so this is a situation where
the federal government might say hey our
economy is at risk from overheating
that's typically not what they say they
tend to like it because it's good for
winning election but they might say if
it's a prudent federal government they
might say hey this is a time to maybe
pay down some of the government debt or
be a little bit more fiscally
responsible and so what they might do is
have a contractionary fiscal policy so
that would be
taxes
might increase and or
government
spending
might go down neither of these things
tend to be very popular in general
contractionary fiscal policy is not a
good way to win elections but a prudent
government might will it be willing to
do this and either of them because of
the same reasons we just talked about
might have the effect of shifting
aggregate demand to the left similarly
the federal reserve might want to do a
contractionary monetary policy and
contractionary monetary policy is far
more common where the federal reserve
says hey when we are producing above our
full employment output inflation might
get out of control so what they might do
is lower the money supply
money supply
which would have the impact or usually
would have the impact of increasing
interest rates making borrowing more
expensive so people might borrow and
spend less and corporations might invest
less and so either way you might have
the effect of shifting aggregate demand
to the left so aggregate demand
might look like this now that's
aggregate demand two our equilibrium
level of output now is at full
employment output and now our price
level our price level has gone down
and generally speaking
contractionary monetary policy and or
contractionary fiscal policy will have
the impact of at least slowing down
inflation
i'll leave you there the big takeaway
here is fiscal policy and monetary
policy seldom act in isolation
oftentimes when we're at a negative
output gap you have expansionary
policies in both dimensions and in a
positive output gap it might be prudent
to have contractionary policies in both
dimensions
now one question you might ask is what
if they go in opposite directions what
if say fiscal policy is expansionary
while monetary policy is contractionary
well there it depends they might offset
each other in fact sometimes the central
bank might have a contractionary policy
because they think that the federal
government is being too expansionary
all interesting things to think about